darauf den heute abend hey joe biden
seine state of the union -rede alexander
kähler debattiert das jetzt mit seinen
gästen
den pazifik fest im blick nicht mehr den
atlantik zu wurden nahezu
unwidersprochen die globalen ambitionen
der usa beschrieben bis vor wenigen
tagen dann kam eine 180 grad drehung
beileibe nicht die einzige seit dem
russischen über verlauf der ukraine joe
biden will sich heute nacht auch dazu
der eigenen nation erklären in der state
of the union address der jährlichen
ansprache an die us bevölkerung
schließlich hat wladimir putin den
einsatz von atomwaffen ins spiel
gebracht und natürlich werden auch
ansagen zur amerikanischen innenpolitik
erwartet
putins drohungen wie reagierten jetzt in
der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns man die
gäste zunächst zugeschaltet ist sigmar
gabriel früherer spd vorsitzender
bundesaußenminister und inzwischen
vorsitzender der atlantik-brücke einer
organisation die sich die
transatlantischen beziehungen zur
herzenssache gemacht hat in washington
mitte sich meinen kollegen emma thompson
den leiter des zdf-studios in der
us-hauptstadt hier im studio sind geld
haft deutsch amerikanische entertainerin
wechselt aber heute mit und für uns ins
ernste fach wegen des ukraine krieges
sie machen keinen hehl aus ihrer
sympathie für die us-demokraten
und legen der wahl von donald trump zum
us-präsidenten sind sie 2017 auch oder
haben die deutsche staatsbürgerschaft
angenommen und schließlich professorin
christiane lemke
politikwissenschaftlerin mit dem
schwerpunkt internationale beziehungen
an der leibniz universität in hannover
elmar in der ukraine bahnt sich
möglicherweise eine tragödie
unvorstellbaren ausmaßes an was wird da
heute nacht von joe biden in seiner
state of the union address erwartet
ja der us präsident hatte sich das
sicher anders vorgestellt er wollte die
state of der junien eigentlich dazu
nutzen um auf seine wirtschaftlichen
erfolge in den usa hinzuweisen obwohl
gleichzeitig die umfragewerte für ihn
auf einem niedrig stand sind und
irgendwie die stimmung auch schlecht ist
in den usa jetzt muss er sich um eine
ganz große außenpolitische krise kümmern
das ist eine riesige gefahr aber auch
ein stück weit eine chance denn
republikaner und demokraten im kongress
sind sich in der frage hartes vorgehen
gegenüber russland und putin nicht
komplett einig aber weitgehend einig es
gibt abweichler innerhalb der
republikanischen partei aber hartes
auftreten möglicherweise auch härter als
es beiden in den letzten tagen und
wochen getan hat findet zustimmung in
beiden parteien und das könnte heute
abend dazu führen bei der state of juni
das er erstens von allen mit applaus
begrüsst wird weil er es geschafft hat
die verbündeten zusammenzuhalten
zweitens dass er in seiner rede in deren
ersten teil er wahrscheinlich auf der
ukraine krise eingehen wird auch an der
einen oder anderen stelle applaus von
beiden seiten haben wird was bei der
polarisierung im land eben nicht
selbstverständlich herr gabriel jetzt
gibt es ja schon sanktionen gegen
russland und auch waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine können die usa kann der
westen noch mehr tun wenn das
blutvergießen unvermindert weitergeht
also ich natürlich kann man sich
vorstellen dass es auch noch weitere
maßnahmen in sanktions bereich gibt aber
was der westen nicht tun würde das man
einfach einmal deutlich aussprechen
weder die vereinigten staaten nach
europa werden das tun sie werden nicht
militärisch gegen russland vorgehen weil
uns das in die nähe eines network
krieges bringen würde insofern ist man
in einer solchen situation als demokrat
der nicht krieg als mittel der politik
empfindet erstmal auf der kurzen strecke
im nachteil ich glaube allerdings auch
wer diesen job eine große chance hat
weil ich erinnere mich noch daran nicht
nur in den usa aber auch in den usa wo
ja die nato in frage gestellt unter
anderem von damals in europa ist sie als
hirntot vom französischen präsidenten
erklärt worden und ich glaube selbst
wladimir putin ist überrascht darüber
wie stark der westen und die nato
zusammen hält ich glaube dass der
amerikanische präsident für sich in
anspruch nehmen kann etwas geschafft zu
haben was so lange nicht stattgefunden
hat nämlich tatsächlich das bündnis
hinter der führung und unter der führung
der vereinigten staaten zu vereinen das
war ja die große fähigkeit der
vereinigten staaten als supermacht im
unterschied zu china der sowjetunion
oder russland die usa sind das einzige
land das in der lage war allianzen zu
bilden alle ihr zu schaffen es gab gibt
keinen alliierten chinas es gab nie
einen der sowjetunion oder russlands gab
abhängige länder ja aber keine
alliierten das war die große fähigkeit
der usa und damit auch ihr
multiplikator von macht und dass die
beiden das wieder ermöglicht hat und im
gegensatz dazu jump nahezu dabei war das
zu zerstören das glaube ich bringt ihn
an eine ziemlich starke position es ist
das geld habe schon angeklungen arbeiten
ist ja hat ja bisher in seiner den
ersten jahr seiner amtszeit nicht gerade
glücklich agiert hatte den durch seine
haltung zur russischen aggression schon
wieder an ansehen gewonnen merkt man das
schon ich glaube dorf ist ein anfang
mindestens davon es ist schwierige
zeiten in america ich glaube genau wie
hier in europa und hier in deutschland
leute sind müde von corona alle sind so
fertig mit diese ganze maßnahmen es ist
die sind jetzt ein bisschen vor uns
jetzt die masken pflicht geht weg
meistens nicht schule und
es wird ein bisschen aufgelockert das
hilft aber inflation ist ganz ganz hoch
der schlimmste inflation seit 40 jahren
leute fügen dass auch wie hier jetzt
wenn man tankt oder oder
im zimmer macht auch noch schlimmer
ergänzung sogar schlimmer und und das
ist in die leute sind müde ich glaube
ich weiß meine eigene familie wir haben
gewartet ok joe biden kommt mindestens
nach dieser verrückte vier jahren ein
bisschen bodenständigkeit ein bisschen
klarheit und er würde alles wieder in
ordnung bringen natürlich könnte er
nicht corona heilen oder die sensation
stoppen aber in so ich glaube
mindestens wie herr thesen ist ein sagt
ein
bisschen zusammenhalt das gleicht ein
wunder eigentlich wenn beide seiten
abrasiert für joe biden heute haben das
ist irgendwie heil wo es um die ukraine
und so geriet angeht frau lemke das
heißt also da wird er wahrscheinlich
applaus bekommen im zweiten teil der
motive sind es ja gerade angedeutet da
geht es dann um innenpolitische fragen
corona ist ja immer noch in den usa ein
wichtiges thema inflation auch die
gescheit zum teil gescheiterten oder
formen von joe biden da wird es dann
wahrscheinlich weniger zustimmung geben
genau also wenn man sich die
umfragewerte anschaut dann sind sie auf
einem tiefpunkt glaube letzte woche
diese woche 33 prozent nach umfragen
stimmen der amtsführung von
joe biden zu und das ist eine
dramatische rückgang gegenüber letzten
jahr im frühjahr als er sehr schwungvoll
antrat joe biden sagte america ist beck
und große reformprojekte angepackt hat
aber davon eigentlich nur einen teil das
infrastrukturpaket hat überhaupt
durchsetzen können und da ist jetzt eine
innenpolitische blockade und die
amerikaner sehen es geht nicht recht
voran und man muss sehen dass innen
politik in den usa ungleich viel
wichtiger ist als außenpolitische fragen
trotz dieser besonderen situation
es gibt den schönen satz der prophet
gilt ja im eigenen land bekanntlich
nichts jetzt hat ja joe biden vor
dem überfall russlands auf die ukraine
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
geheimdiensterkenntnisse das ist steht
unmittelbar bevor man hat ihnen nicht so
richtig geglaubt vielleicht weil man
auch noch gehofft hat es passiert nicht
lag das auch ein bisschen daran dass
sich die dass ich eine amtsvorgänger von
ihm und seine administration 2003 beim
irak krieg eine handfeste lüge erlaubt
hat
also das spielt glaube ich besonders bei
uns europäern eine große rolle weil wir
dieses bild natürlich im kopf haben als
colin powell vor den vereinten nationen
gelogen hat eindeutig nachweisbar und
das schwang dann mit als tony blinken
vor kurzem dann vor dem
weltsicherheitsrat eben auch aufgetreten
ist aber man muss man einst klare klar
sagen glaube ich joe biden hatte nach
seiner wahl bei vielen amerikanern erst
mal ich sag mal eine positive
einstellung sowie geld abzuholen
beschrieben hat man hatte die hoffnung
das drama ist ein stück zu ende da ist
einer der ist lange dabei der weiß was
er tut und auch wenn die polarisierung
im land nicht gleich mal mit dem finger
schnippen verschwindet würde er stück
für stück daran bauen können das wieder
in ordnung zu bringen und jetzt kommt
das was ihm widerfahren ist nämlich im
sommer afghanistan und man sieht in den
umfragewerten eindeutig dass das
vorgehen der usa in afghanistan sondern
acht knick erzeugt hat bei der
zustimmungsrate auch dieser abwartenden
haltung in der amerikanischen
bevölkerung
man hat gezweifelt und zwar sowohl
außenpolitisch als auch innenpolitisch
umso verrückter das jetzt vielleicht
eine außenpolitische dazu beitragen kann
so ein bisschen vertrauen wieder
zurückzuerobern in die stärke des weißen
hauses und des präsidenten die
umfragewerte sind schlecht aber es gibt
andere werte die sind gar nicht so
schlecht also wir haben hier in amerika
ein wirtschaftswachstum im letzten jahr
von 5,7 prozent gehabt wir haben eine
arbeitslosenrate jetzt von vier prozent
die niedrigste arbeitslosenrate seit
vielen jahrzehnten es sind 6,7 millionen
neue jobs entstanden das heißt er hätte
eigentlich einiges vorzuweisen
das sind große pakete durch den kongress
gegangen nicht so groß wie beiden sich
das erhofft hatte hat auch krachenden
niederlagen auch in seiner eigenen
partei erlitten aber unterm strich
zeigt in amerika vieles eigentlich in
richtung es geht wieder voran und
insofern kommt es für ihn drauf an und
für seine parteien den nächsten wochen
angefangen heute abend mit der state of
the union address den amerikanern
deutlich zu machen wo denn jetzt schon
erfolge im gange sind er gab mir glauben
sie denn dass wenn joe biden jetzt in
sachen krieg gegen die ukraine richtig
besonnen souverän agiert dass er dann
diese scharte auswetzen kann die er sich
und dem land ja zugefügt hat durch
diesen überstürzten abzug aus
afghanistan
hier in europa und bei den alliierten
der vereinigten staaten ist das ja
bereits der fall das ist ja im gegensatz
zu afghanistan
doch hoch professionell durch die
us-administration hier gelungen die
alliierten hinter sich bei reichen
staaten ausreicht
die politischen probleme zu überwinden
das vermag ich nicht zu beurteilen ich
glaube jedenfalls das was in enten
entstanden ist nämlich die spaltung der
band ist ein symptom dafür gewesen und
nicht etwa die ursache das ist eben auch
nicht in anderthalb jahren oder in etwas
etwas mehr als einem jahr wieder gut zu
machen dafür wird man längere zeit
brauchen aber möglicherweise hilft ihm
exakt diese außenpolitische krise an
standing zu gewinnen mein eindruck ist
dass jedenfalls
wir können im moment gabriel zu hören
aber nicht sehen frau lemke die schwäche
der usa in den letzten jahren die hat
mir ein vakuum geschaffen
das jetzt putin hinein stößt da sehen
wir im nahen osten sind in westafrika
jetzt in der ukraine
sind die usa mit verursacher dieser
krise dieser scharfen krise jetzt in der
welt
also ich denke dass die usa tatsächlich
in den letzten jahren diplomatie
vernachlässigt haben insbesondere
während der tramp administration sich
sehr zurückgezogen haben auf eigene
interessen aber man darf nicht vergessen
dass die usa sehr viele verbündete sehr
viele freunde haben und zwar rund um den
globus nicht nur in europa und von daher
in einer ungleich stärkeren situation
sind als russland es ist das nämlich
keine freunde hat außer vielleicht
belarus und einige länder die sagen na
ja vielleicht hat russland doch ein
richtig ein argument oder einen
richtigen ansatz aber man kann sagen
russland ist isoliert haben die usa zu
dieser krise beigetragen also ich bin da
sehr kritisch gegenüber der these dass
die nato eine mitschuld trägt an dem
überfall auf die ukraine jemand dass man
putin ermuntert durch dieses verhalten
in den letzten jahren ja man fragt sich
ja warum er jetzt gerade nicht seine
truppe in bewegung gesetzt hat warum er
mit einem atomkrieg droht warum macht er
das jetzt und er hat tatsächlich gemeint
die usa sind schwach aber auch europa
ist schwach deutschland hat eine neue
regierung der er nichts zutraut und
insofern hat er sich in allen drei
fragen komplett verschätzt aber ja er
hat die usa als schwach wahrgenommen
gabriel eine frage noch sie kennen ja
putin persönlich von begegnungen hätten
sie eine solche grenzüberschreitung für
möglich gehalten wie sie gerade
stattfindet mit der begründung von ihm
eine reminiszenz an die vergangenheit
russlands damit zu begründen dass man
die vergangenheit die glorreiche
russische vergangenheit wieder
aufrichten will dass man also mit einer
solchen begründung das geht ja zum teil
bis ins frühe mittelalter zurück mit
einer solchen begründung einen solchen
brutalen krieg vom zaun brechen kann
nein natürlich nicht wenn ich das für
möglich gehalten hätte hätte ich mich
nie betroffen
aber ich glaube das finde ich gut an der
in dem was wir eben gehört haben es geht
nicht um die ukraine ich glaube dass es
wirklich ein trugschluss zu glauben
russland reagiert auf eine angebliche
einkreisung der nato und fühlt sich in
seinen
sicherheitsanforderungen bedrängt mal
abgesehen davon dass diese länder nun
wirklich das recht selbst zu entscheiden
und wir nicht mehr zu zeiten sozusagen
von jalta sind wo die nachbarn von
großmächten erst mal fragen müssen wenn
sich in der außenpolitik bewegen wollen
aber es geht glaube ich auch russland um
was ganz anderes wladimir putin sieht
oder hat gesehen dass russland
insbesondere in europa seit 1990 an
einfluss verloren hat das land ist
herabgesunken auf den status eines
energielieferanten
es hat keinen politischen einfluss auf
die entwicklung europas mehr nehmen
können es ist wirtschaftlich nicht
attraktiv ist politisch nicht attraktiv
und das mittel das ihm geblieben ist um
das wieder zurückzudrehen ist eben sein
militär was er wirklich will ist glaube
ich zurück in europa eine großmacht zu
werden die über das schicksal europas
mindestens mit entscheiden können und
natürlich auch international deswegen
führt der krieg im nahen osten deswegen
schickt er seine söldner nach mali also
es geht glaube ich nicht um die ukraine
das ein mittel zu dem eigentlichen zweck
russland wieder als großmacht zu zu
etablieren insbesondere in europa und
das kann natürlich für uns europäer nur
gefährlich seien deswegen wenn wir ihnen
damit durchkommen lassen würden dann
wären wir hier in europa spiel bei
seiner groß machtinteressen und deswegen
glaube ich darf man weder der russischen
propaganda nachlaufen
und schon gar nicht den eindruck
erwecken wir seien sozusagen selbst
schuld in wahrheit ist der beitritt der
osteuropäischen staaten zur nato hat
seinen zu rüsten stabilität seit dem
westfälischen frieden geführt in europa
und russland allerdings eben aus der
rolle des sozusagen der der europäischen
großmacht herausgedrängt und david zu
wollen und dafür nutzt er die ukraine
aber es geht nicht um die ukraine selbst
sondern um die rolle und das
selbstverständnis russlands putin nimmt
den starken mann starke männer kommen in
der welt zum teil sehr gut an was
erwartet man jetzt von joe biden in
dieser situation in den usa die usa
gelten als weltpolizist sie haben
überall eingegriffen pax americana
nannte man das also eine ein system nach
dem wunsch der usa
muss er wurde ja von trump als liebe zum
schläfer bezeichnet muss er da noch viel
mehr an statur gewinnen ich hab gesagt
vor den war was joe biden ist für vier
amerikaners everybody's oper er ist wie
ein großvater und denn das kann man
positiv oder negativ negativ sagt manns
libido pause das hat man genug jetzt das
ist so eine also sein agiere europa sagt
man der arme mann lebt er anscheinend
von red bull und gran hof denke es ist
ich weiß nicht wer kriegt diese energie
weil man sieht er ist auch er ist nur 1
70 das ist wahnsinnig viel stress für
die gesundheit eines jeden
79 jahre man aber ich glaube genau das
in der positive sind sozusagen soweit er
nicht weiter jemandes hier okay das ist
dan das ist was wir brauchen wir
brauchen grenzen halt einfach so gegen
diese feinde oder jemand der uns
zusammenbringt und auch hat immer noch
die beiden hat immer noch ein bisschen
besonnenheit es wird okay er hat einen
grund optimismus in ein vertrauen in die
vereinigten staaten und in unserem land
unsere bevölkerung verfängt diese
besonnenheit in usa die mediale
verbreitung von image ist daher
besonders wichtig nicht erst heute am
jahr von donald trump wir wie stellte
oder wird er in den medien gerade
dargestellt ist da das besondere auch
wichtig und ist das auch etwas was die
amerikaner im moment in dieser situation
gut finden was ich sehe einfach in dem
in meiner branche so fern von den
comedians von der late night talkshows
usw die ein wichtiger gewicht in amerika
haben diese jeden jeden nach deinen
kommentar ein bisschen sport ein
bisschen satire die sind alle
zurückgegangen mit deren kritik an ihnen
dass das er ist ein bisschen vergesslich
dass er ist ein bisschen es gibt ein
bestimmtes genre joe biden das ist alles
jetzt in die letzte woche werden die
leute sind ich finde
medial hinter ihnen doch wir sind ein
bisschen zusammen aus amerikanern sn wir
müssen auch nicht vergessen es gibt
kritische leute sind da wie viele leute
von ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken länder
die ihre merkel senden haben familien
freunde hier im treuen in die ukraine
natürlich das ist ein sehr emotionaler
frage für deutsche familien freunde sind
hier hält man jetzt hat ja die
ankündigung von putin dass er die
abschreckungs waffen oder die
abschreckungs streitmacht der in erhöhte
alarmbereitschaft gesetzt hat am letzten
sonntag dazu gehören auch gehört auch
die atomare bewaffnung der russischen
armee die raketentruppen ja großes
aufsehen erregt auch in den usa wie ist
das da eigentlich aufgenommen worden ist
als drohgebärde aufgenommen worden was
es ja auch wahr oder steckt da mehr
dahinter und wie versucht die us
administration jetzt mit diesen viele
menschen doch ziemlich erschreckenden
umstand umzugehen
ich glaube hier wird besonders deutlich
was für ein unterschied ist dass joe
biden jetzt präsident der vereinigten
staaten ist weil donald trump hat man
möglicherweise mit einer gegen- oder
überreaktion rechnen müssen dass er dann
feuer entführer das mal gegenüber team
in nordkorea angekündigt hat androht das
ist bei joe biden nicht der fall man war
überrascht dass putin so deutlich so
eine ankündigung im fern sinn macht
andererseits auch nicht weil es
entspricht der russischen militärdoktrin
das kann man nachlesen auf papier die
seit einigen jahren gilt dass man eben
immer mal wieder auch in diesen
auseinandersetzungen mit dem
atomwaffenpotenzial
russlands droht am ende kommt immer
darauf an ob dann tatsächlich auch das
geschieht was angedroht wird sprich die
truppenteile entsprechenden bereitschaft
versetzt werden auch das wurde gestern
behauptet vom kreml aber die amerikaner
schauen gerade sehr genau hin was
passiert da man kann weil man ja über
die jahrzehnte eine art ja mechanismus
hat wie man gegenseitig auch
kontrolliert was passiert mit den
atomwaffen können auch die amerikaner
sehr genau sehen werden beispielsweise
bei den nicht strategischen atomwaffen
das sind die nicht
interkontinentalraketen die kleineren
die gewissermaßen auch taktisch
eingesetzt werden könnten die werden
getrennt gelagert diese raketen von den
gefechtsköpfen von den sprengköpfen das
heißt man beobachtet genau gibt es
bewegungen die darauf hindeuten dass
diese sprengköpfe jetzt auf die raketen
drauf gesetzt werden gibt es bewegungen
dahin das u boote aus den hafen
auslaufen oder dass die entsprechenden
mobilen
raketensysteme ins land hinaus geschickt
werden und natürlich kann man vielleicht
auch sehen da wo interkontinentalraketen
sind ob sich da was tut und die ansage
aus dem pentagon von gestern nachmittag
jedenfalls war man sieht keine
wesentlich erhöhten aktivitäten insofern
hat man hier in amerika nicht die
alarmbereitschaft erhöht weil man eben
auch nicht in sonnen eskalation circle
in so einem teufelskreis hinein kommen
will man schaut sehr genau hin aber das
weiße haus handelt sehr überlegt und
versucht auch bei den öffentlichen
kommentaren er klar zu machen dass eine
weitere provokation von putin
aber man muss nicht leicht dann in panik
verfallen und denken morgen kommt es zum
atomkrieg herr gabriel wird durch dieses
verhalten das mrt wissen da gerade
geschildert hat in bezug auf diese
drogen mit atomaren vernichtungswaffen
wird da da könnte tatsächlich die gewalt
spirale die sich diese
eskalationsspirale sich dann immer
weiter drehen würde durchbrochen werden
also nicht dass bei dem er putin und vor
allem auch nicht sein umfeld die gefahr
unterschätzen würden die an nuklearer
auseinandersetzung auf der russland
bedeuten würde das gäbe unfassbar viele
opfer auch in russland ich habe er eine
andere sorge dass uns putin in eine
situation hinein treibt wo wir wieder
über lange jahre eine grenze quer opa
haben werden wo wir uns bis an die zähne
bewaffnet gegenüberstehen denn natürlich
wird diese krise zur folge haben dass
die nato jetzt dahin geht wo sie bislang
nicht ist nämlich in den osteuropäischen
mitgliedsstaaten der nato
das ist ja eine behauptung von wladimir
putin die nato habe sich bis an seine
grenze ausgedehnt das stimmt ja nicht
sondern mit der nato russland grund akte
und den beitritt der osteuropäer zur
nato die russland übrigens damals
unterschrieben hat ist ja verabredet
worden dass die nato nicht in die
osteuropäischen staaten mit großen
gruppen verbänden und waffensystemen
geht die russland bedrohen könnte das
wird allerdings jetzt der fall sein und
in zeiten von cyberattacken und fake
propaganda steigt natürlich die gefahr
von missverständnissen
von
auseinandersetzungen die möglicherweise
gar nicht gewollt werden nichts von dem
was früher mal existiert dazwischen der
nato auf der einen seite und der alten
sowjetunion und später russland auf der
anderen seite sozusagen gegenseitige
informationen
transparenz bei militärübungen damit
niemand das verhalten des anderen falsch
interpretieren gar nichts davon
existiert heute und also die vorstellung
zu haben dass diese beiden systeme sich
hochgerüstet direkt gegenüber stehen in
europa verbunden mit solchen drohungen
aus russland davor das ist im wahrsten
sinne des wortes furchterregend putin
zwingt uns in dieser lage hinein von
denke wenn wir noch mal ganz kurz auf
das sanktionsregime schauen da soll also
jetzt der transfer von hochtechnologie
nach russland verhindert sie hatten
die finanzströme werden unterbrochen
finanzdienstleister swift nicht mehr für
russische
finanzinstitute erreichbar die
staatsbank wird blockiert damit in
devisen reserven nicht genutzt werden
können weniger um waffen einzukaufen als
vor allem den rubel zu stabilisieren
dass ich auch eine große gefahr für die
für die russische wirtschaft
und es gibt einen bereich wo bisher noch
nicht sanktioniert wird nämlich bei öl
und gas und das gilt nicht nur für
deutschland sondern auch für die usa das
wurde ja von us republikanern auch
kritisiert so lang man dieses
schlupfloch nicht schließt in dem als
durch das quasi öl und gas in den westen
fließen und damit auch die wiesn in die
andere richtung dann sind das gar keine
richtigen sanktionen dann kann man
russland nicht richtig treffen ist das
so eine art doppelmoral wir gehen jetzt
zwar gegen russland vor aber da wo es
uns nützt werden keine sanktionen
verabschiedet also ich sehe das etwas
anders ich denke dass dieses
sanktionspaket wirklich sehr umfangreich
ist sehr hart ist und ja eben nicht nur
von der eu und den usa verhängt wurde
sondern die schweiz macht mit und was
ganz interessant ist auch großbritannien
gerade da wird ja vieles geld das die
russischen oligarchen lagern in london
direkt aufbewahrt also es ist eine sehr
breite unterstützung für die sanktionen
und ich denke in der kombination die da
erreicht worden ist und zwar einstimmig
alle machen mit bei diesen sanktionen
und das ist ja auch sehr schnell
etabliert worden
werden wir schon effekte sehen auf die
russische wirtschaft und vor allen
dingen was ich ganz interessant fand
dass die oligarchen also die milliardäre
die putin ja sozusagen umgeben und ihn
auch bislang gestützt haben in einem
brief an putin gesagt haben den krieg
das wollen sie nicht ist ja klar weil
sie geld verlieren und eben gerade wenn
also die ganzen bank beschränkungen auch
durchgesetzt werden
glaube ich gibt es einen inneren
widerstand in russland aus dieser
kleinen clique der oligarchen oder so
klein ist sie gar nicht und das ist die
einzige chance auch für veränderung also
ich glaube dass putin selber sich nicht
verändern wird und dass er auch niemand
ist der irgendwann einknickt und sagt
okay jetzt gehe ich an den
verhandlungstisch also es muss schon
druck von innen entstehen jetzt geht ja
nicht nur um das vermögen und die
freunde von milliardären ist ist ja
möglich daß durch die sanktionen eben
auch wirtschaftliche komplikationen
wirtschaftlicher krisen rezession im
westen steht auch in den usa zum
beispiel durch ausbleibende
energielieferungen durch höhere kosten
auch das diesen effekt gibt es in den
usa bereits
was passiert dann wie reagiert dann die
amerikanische bevölkerung wenn die
kosten der freiheit wie es so schön
heißt in rechnung gestellt werden ich
glaube es gibt eine bestimmte
patriotismus im moment sind alle
zusammen denn man sah das paradies katar
in einer preisverleihung des
und das war natürlich alle haben
politische statements gemerkt alle
schauspieler haben blauen getragen und
das war wirklich toll dieser
zusammenhalt oder
der große comedy show am samstagabend
die haben statt mit comedy angefangen
eine ukrainische chor die haben die
ukrainische nationalhymne gesungen es
war sehr bewegend ich glaube dass ein
bestimmt auch durch kultur 1 1 große
bitte es gibt einen grund warum wie im
zweiten weltkrieg wird wir schaffen das
die as we can
die amerikanische behaupten zusammen war
will wissen warum wie lange das dauert
wie lang diese
guten aussichten gebäude oder diese
zusammenhalt gibt dass es
sehr sehr schwierig wie uns hier in
deutschland auch so warten sobald es
kommt so mein auto mein haus mein
heizung mein
erster wahl weizen wird auch teurer
brot wird teurer das ist eine sehr gute
frage wie lang wird das wie wir das tun
wie kann man die wii können wie kann joe
biden und seine regierung die normalen
menschen herausfinden unterstützung in
dieser schwierigen zeiten
immer tief ist und jetzt gibt es ja
nicht nur diese frage wie man die
bevölkerung bei solchen sanktionen bei
der stange hält den usa kommt doch der
spezielle aspekt dazu wir haben es
vorhin schon kurz angedeutet das ist ja
ein tiefes zerwürfnis gibt im land
gelesen die usa seien im haus nur noch
verein das land sei gespalten könnte es
denn sein dass zum beispiel die
republikaner jetzt im vorfeld auch der
kongresswahlen im herbst dieses thema
sanktionen krieg in der ukraine noch
instrumentalisieren für in politik und
damit diese geschlossene haltung die die
usa in solchen situationen nach außen
normalerweise zeigen
konterkarieren
absolut und das ist auch schon im gange
es gibt innerhalb der republikanischen
partei hatte eben verschiedene flügel
der eine ist der ganze extreme der
lieber
der im grunde genommen sagt beiden ist
schuld an all dem putin wäre niemals in
der ukraine einmarschiert wenn donald
trump noch präsident wäre das werden sie
in der wahl oder im wahlkampf natürlich
überall an jeder ecke zu hören bekommen
und insbesondere wird dann darauf
verwiesen werden das passiert auch jetzt
schon dass die hohen benzinpreise
natürlich damit zusammen hängen mit der
schwäche joe biden mit dem was da gerade
mit putin passiert und so weiter da
helfen auch die ölreserven die jetzt
freigegeben werden das haben sich ja ich
glaube dutzende von ländern rund um den
erdball verpflichtet die ölproduktion
entsprechend zu erhöhen bzw auch die
ölreserven freizugeben in hohem umfang
um die preise wieder ein bisschen zu
drücken aber die inflation im land ist
7,5 prozent und das führt dazu dass bei
wahlen die meistens anhand von
wirtschaftlichen themen entschieden
werden in den usa
dass eine offene flanke für joe biden
ist und in der republikanischen partei
gibt es auch noch die anderen die sagen
auch er müsste noch viel härter gegen
wladimir putin vorgehen er müsste
tatsächlich auch bereit sein direkt in
die militärische konfrontation zu gehen
was eine katastrophe wäre weil das in
der tat gleich den großen konflikt
zwischen europa und russland auslösen
würde das eine ganz schwierige situation
und wir müssen damit rechnen dass bei
den wahlen joe biden die mehrheiten in
beiden häusern des kongresses verliert
das wäre sowieso schon knapp geworden
angesichts der ich sag mal polarisierung
im land und der inflation die wir haben
und ähnlichem jetzt kommt noch etwas
dazu was
instrumentalisiert werden kann und
insofern ist wirklich ein großes
fragezeichen wie handlungsfähig der
amerikanische präsident in seiner in der
zweiten hälfte seiner amtszeit nun ist
falls der amerikanische kongress
tatsächlich im november kippen sollte
herr gabriel handlungsfähigkeit des
us-präsidenten sie haben es gerade schon
mal ganz kurz angesprochen es gibt ja
auch die kriegsführung mit cyberwaffen
die kann man ja auch staatlicherseits
ganz gezielt anwenden sehen sie da eine
weitere eskalationsgefahr ist es möglich
dass sich entweder russland oder später
die usa auch mit cyberwaffen wert also
einen richtigen cyber krieg vom zaun
bricht das ja auch schon so etwas fast
wie eine nukleare option
naja ich hab mir gerade vor kurzem das
gegenteil erlebt nach dem treffen von
joe biden und wladimir putin in genf
kam es ja tatsächlich zu der reaktion
dass putin etwas dagegen getan hat das
aus russland heraus nicht staatlich
organisierte
cyberattacken eingestellt wurden also
auch die amerikanischen dienste haben ja
bestätigt dass beiden der diesen diese
kritik putin gegenüber vorgetragen hat
und aufgefordert hat dass sein zu lassen
dass tatsächlich russland darauf
reagiert hat aber genauso gut kann
natürlich in einer wachsenden
konfrontation russland das auch wieder
hochfahren es muss nicht mal staatliche
machen sondern kann da eine der privaten
toll fabriken nutzen über es genauso wie
gegen die ukraine das glaube ich ist für
die ukraine auch ein erhebliches risiko
dass russland die dortige infrastruktur
lahm legt das alles ist leider
heutzutage auch gegenstand der
konfrontation
nur wir sehen eben das offensichtlich
der glaube es gäbe keine panzer mehr die
über grenze rollen dass das auch falsch
ist sondern dass er ein zusätzliches
instrument dazu gekommen ist aber die
alten ebenfalls ja schlimm instrumente
der kriegführung die weggefallen sind
ich glaube das hat diesen recht hat mit
dem risiko für beiden aber es gibt auch
ein risiko für die republikaner
sozusagen so klar wie die gemeinsame
haltung von demokraten und republikanern
in der gesamtzeit waren gegen russland
wird es ja bei den republikaner doch
eine menge leute geben die jedenfalls
nicht dafür sind dieses spiel was kommt
versucht hat mit putin zu spielen
mitzumachen es gab ja nichts worin
demokraten und republikaner in der zeit
von donald trump weißen haus so sehr
übereingestimmt haben wie den
präsidenten daran zu hindern mit
wladimir putin sozusagen
sonderabkommen zutreffen putin selber
übrigen muss ich habe ihn mal gefragt
was er von donald trump hält da
wirtschaft noch nicht gewählt und er hat
geantwortet mit einer 20 minütigen
beleidigung von barack obama es war auch
eine antwort und natürlich hat auch
putin darauf gehofft dass dran präsident
wird und ist am ende durch die
gemeinsame haltung von
repräsentantenhaus und senat
daran gehindert worden
diese politik weiter zu machen ist das
noch nicht ohne risiko für die
republikaner jetzt selber
sozusagen als diejenigen aufzutreten
deren präsidentschaftskandidaten zweifel
kamen die absicht hat mit putin einmal
verhältnis zu pflegen bei dem sozusagen
die großen der welt sich die welt
aufteilen tourismus halt zusehen wie ihr
klarkommt also es stimmt alles was
gesagt wurde für die risiken für die
beiden aber es gibt auch risiken für die
republikaner und für ihren
wenn er schon passen sollte lassen sie
uns noch mal ganz kurz auf das thema
cyber krieg zurückkommen ist das eine
neue dimension die sich da auftut
offensichtlich so weit ich das jetzt
mitbekommen hat hat sich arbeiten
irgendwie etwas zurückgehalten bzw
dieses mittel noch so der offensichtlich
diskutiert was bedeutet das eigentlich
für die politischen beziehungen in der
welt diese neue dimension der
kriegsführung und vielleicht auch noch
erklären also es kann damit gezielt wenn
es gelingt infrastruktur lahm gelegt
werden alle öffentlichen
versorgungseinrichtungen strom gas
wasser versorgung der bankensektor das
bedarf man kein geld mehr man kann
überhaupt nicht mehr agieren der
öffentliche nah und fernverkehr kann
komplett lahmgelegt werden klare option
ein land geht auf dem zahnfleisch wird
völlig still gelegt was bedeutet dass
diese neue dimension der kriegsführung
für die zwischenstaatlichen beziehungen
auch in der zukunft
also es ist ja so dass sie bei
cyber-angriffen zunächst mal nicht
unmittelbar feststellen können wer der
angreifer ist und sie können nicht eine
person sozusagen identifizieren oder ein
land das hat ja in der vergangenheit
cyber angriffe gegeben auch in den usa
zum beispiel auf diese öl pipeline die
in den usa von nord nach süd
führt und bei manchen cyber angriffen in
der vergangenheit wie gesagt konnte man
nicht genau feststellen wer das war und
natürlich hat die russische regierung
stets von sich gewiesen dass sie
involviert sei aber wenn man
zurückverfolgt und das kann man
technisch woher kommt jetzt dieser
angriff oder
wer hat sozusagen das system
durcheinander gebracht auch schon sehr
viel genauer den finger drauf tun die
nato hat sich vor einigen jahren bereits
in
die problematik der cyber security also
die sicherheit
in diesem bereich zum thema gemacht und
damit auseinandergesetzt und hat auch
soweit ich weiß eben
strategien um mit solchen cyber
angriffen umzugehen und das ist glaube
ich ganz wichtig weil die nato eben das
technische know how hat aber eben auch
die internationale sozusagen
verflechtung cyber angriffe sind ja nie
sozusagen auf ein land begrenzt sondern
häufig eben soll das
grenzüberschreitend länder treffen und
von daher ist es ganz wichtig dass die
nato eben wie gesagt in den letzten
jahren schon da rein investiert hat und
auch szenarien durchgespielt hat und
sich auch mit den technischen
möglichkeiten solche angriffe abzuwehren
auseinandergesetzt hat
und habt wir haben jetzt gesprochen dass
möglicherweise erst alexander
jall nicht da noch was ergänzen darf wir
haben ja jetzt gerade einen fall von dem
wir noch nicht wissen inwieweit
tatsächlich eine verbindung hat der
ukraine aber gestern sind ja in japan
die werke von toyota gestoppt worden
also die autofertigung weil ein
zulieferbetrieb eben ins ziel von
hackern geraten ist und zwar in einem
umfang wie das glaube ich in den letzten
jahren auch noch nicht der fall war
japan prüft jetzt derzeit ob das
irgendwas mit der ukraine krise zu tun
haben kann klammer auf weil japan als g7
pracht naja sich an den sanktionen
massiv beteiligt hat klammer zu es ist
sicherlich nicht einfach
herauszubekommen woher solche attacken
kommen aber jens stoltenberg der
nato-generalsekretär hat ja vor ein paar
tagen sehr sehr klar gemacht bei einer
pressekonferenz dass eine cyber attacke
auf ein nato-mitglied auch ein fall für
den artikel 5 sein könnte also
tatsächlich dann auch eine antwort der
gesamten nato herausfordern würde das
gilt für japan natürlich nicht aber das
gilt für alle
nato staat nur insofern kann eine
cyber-attacke gleich zu einem großen
konflikt zwischen der nato und russland
führen und hier rätseln in washington
zur zeit alle erstens warum er es selber
noch nicht eingesetzt hat in der ukraine
offenbar in einem sehr beschränkten
ausmaß wenn überhaupt in der ukraine
eingesetzt das kommunikationssystem und
das internet funktionierten da in den
letzten tagen eigentlich weiterhin recht
gut und zum zweiten wann der punkt kommt
an dem russland tatsächlich dass
überkapazitäten verfügt in dem bereich
bereit wären es cyber attacke auch gegen
die nato partner die eu oder die
vereinigten staaten zu finden er gab mir
das wird ja bedeuten bei dieser artikel
5 aktivität also wenn ein land
angegriffen wird in dem fall mit
cyberwaffen dass sich die nato zur wehr
setzen darf sich gemeinsam verteidigen
darf da die bundeswehr eine
parlamentsarmee ist ist es aber auch
eine sache des deutschen bundestages der
ja regelrecht dann möglicherweise auch
sauber gegenwehr genehmigen muss darüber
würde glaube ich unter juristen gerade
auch gestritten in deutschland ob das so
sein muss
ja weil in der tat die frage ist das ein
angriff oder nicht
auch in der deutschen rechtsprechung
sehr unterschiedlich beurteilt wird aber
ich meine eins ist doch klar würde es
einen solchen cyber angriff gegen den
ehemann zurückverfolgen können in
bestimmten bereichen kann man das
vielleicht nicht sofort aber mit
zeitlicher verzögerung dann glaube ich
wird auch die bundesrepublik deutschland
wird auch das deutsche parlament
nicht nichts daran hindern eine einer
nato gegenmaßnahme zuzustimmen die frage
ist sind wir dann mittendrin in einer
eskalation einer direkten konfrontation
zwischen nato und russland und wo endet
die das glaube ich es eher das problem
verlassen wir uns am ende der sendung
kurz auf den hauptdarsteller der
laufenden 8 zu bekommen auf fidschi
beiden wir haben ja darüber gesprochen
wie weit er jetzt möglicherweise da eine
gute figur macht und viele viele
schatten aussetzen kann auf die längere
sicht betrachtet bisher ist es ja nur
den baron von münchhausen gelungen sich
an den eigenen haaren aus dem sumpf zu
ziehen ist schon bald vielleicht der
zweite hat wirklich in der chance kann
er vielleicht sogar noch ein großer
präsident werden was glauben sie ich
hoffe
große ganze positiver es ist auch mit
der männlichkeit mit der der führer des
vertrauten ich hoffe dass er bleibt joe
biden dass er aber dass er stärker zeigt
dass er durchhaltevermögen hast genau
das für alle was für eine runde ich bin
mehrmals hier aber ich denke er so gut
ist die information zu hören aber diese
nicht diesen dunklen zeiten das wir
erleben und ich hoffe dass er das joe
biden die die talent hat einfach leute
zusammenhalten und irgendwie für frieden
zu arbeiten man könnte das auch ganz
anders ausgehen in malabo in da lauert
immer noch donald trump dass er dann am
ende doch der profiteur dieses
konfliktes dieses krieges gegen die
ukraine sein könnte
ja das könnte und das wäre extra traurig
ich sag's mal ehrlich was vielen nicht
auffällt aber wenn man genauer hinschaut
sieht man dass die administration beiden
harris hat im vergangenen jahr 2,8
billionen dollar mobilisiert bekommen
durch den amerikanischen kongress die
ihnen die amerikanische infrastruktur
und in die unterstützung der wirtschaft
fließen natürlich ist ja auch krachend
gescheitert mit einem weiteren sehr
großen paket aber allein diese pakete in
diesem ausmaß sorgen jetzt schon und wir
haben uns das im land angeschaut dafür
dass in zukunftstechnologien investiert
wird da werden werke wieder aufgemacht
werden neue werke gebaut
gerade im bereich halbleitertechnik
gerade im bereich batterien und
elektroautos dahin stehen neue jobs und
zwar in großer zahl und auch weltweit
ist einiges im gange was wir vielleicht
gar nicht so wahrnehmen dass die usa
jetzt übrigens auch gemeinsam mit der eu
sich milliarden von dollar investieren
in wirtschafts unterstützung
infrastruktur pakete in afrika in
südamerika mannschaft bündnisse und zwar
nicht indem man mit billig krediten
versucht einfluss zu gewinnen sondern in
erster linie versucht die infrastruktur
in diesen ländern voranzutreiben auf
augenhöhe mit diesen ländern und da sind
wir auch unterwegs gewesen wir sehen im
grunde um das eine menge im gang
gekommen wo finanzielles und politisches
kapital aus den usa investiert wird und
jetzt kommt das problem die frage ist ob
bei den zwischenwahlen das ergebnis
dafür sorgt dass das noch eine weile
wirkung entfalten kann oder ob bei der
zwischenwahl das gegenteil passiert
möglicherweise diese entwicklung
abgewürgt und spätestens dann mit der
nächsten präsidentschaftswahl
komplett wieder zerstört werden könnte
gut das müssen wir abwarten das sind
positive wie negative möglicherweise
negative aussichten ich bedanke mich bei
sigmar gabriel beim at wissen aus
washington neben studio bargeld haft und
bei christiane lemke um 3 uhr heute
nacht die state of the union address von
joe biden die rede an die nation
natürlich live bei phoenix aber wir
senden in der ganzen nacht nicht nur zu
diesem thema sondern auch zu neuigkeiten
im krieg im angriffskrieg oder zum
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine bleiben
sie bei uns
[Musik]
november 2013
massenproteste auf dem majdan in kiew
sie demonstrierten für eine öffnung der
ukraine richtung europa ihr präsident
viktor janukowitsch hatte ihnen genau
diese öffnung verweigert stattdessen der
einvernehmliche schulterschluss mit
russlands präsident wladimir putin
die proteste markierten für